it's an unplanned stop near saluted sir
in Serbia for ali reza and his family
the old tile factory here was supposed
to be just a station along the way but
the fence now standing at Hungry's
border means the family must rethink
their route 28 days gorgeous way eight
volunteers bring them food and drink and
toys offer a bit of welcome distraction
to the children but ali reza says he's
worried he doesn't know what to do next
one of the volunteers tells him to
change cause turn around and head to
croatia she says the border there is
open but it's a detour that requires
additional strength after a short break
they decide to try they're not the only
ones who have acted on this information
bus after bus arrives and she'd near the
border to Croatia all full of refugees
they have to continue from here on foot
step by step across the border some of
them have come from [ __ ] gosh others
directly from the border to Macedonia
that's where r mod has been the syrian
engineer and his wife heard about the
fence in hungary so they're trying their
luck here some people told us is easy
can crushing from this rod butter we
don't know what happen together with
hundreds of others they trudged for
miles through the fields until they
finally brought to a stop
croatian police lead them in small
groups to buses many of the refugees
have had bad experiences with people in
uniform fears run high especially when
they're put in different vehicles from
each other you don't have to worry you
will find them even if they aren't you
in this plane yeah don't be scared out
which is gonna be all right the police
take the refugees on to tour varnak the
short trip takes them a little closer to
their goal north and western europe